tu peux pas savoir comme quand on a dit
aux fans aux gens sur les sites et tout
ça c'est georges unis et dans l'émission
il était très heureux c'est super gentil
wel gp gym et que vous avez hésité cette
semaine
oui non oui non je veux pas et je veux
pas venir sur des embrouilles voilà je
veux venir que sur des vannes des
conneries débat nas la base navale
[Applaudissements]
non c'est sur la vanne la vanne la balle
mais forcément on va dire un tout petit
mot pour les gens qui ont oublié ce que
vous êtes arrivé après on passe à la
base navale
et jeudi pour les gens
deux phrases moi je veux qu'on parle de
l'artiste et ben justement l'artiste
artistes de l'ombre n'ont pas l'aptitude
or mon nom d'artiste texte justement
l'article texte qu'est ce qu'il fait
depuis trois ans parce que moi j'entends
que vous êtes comédiens et je le sais
vous faites du one man et je le sais
vous faisiez de la radio et de la télé
aujourd'hui vous faites quoi regarde
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
tu sais là on subit là les locaux vides
abaddon froid donc c'est délicat de dire
ce confiance en moi je fais plein de
spectacles je suis sur une les projets
de pièces de théâtre et les radios etc à
droite à gauche mais en privilégiant les
choses qui se prennent pas au sérieux et
ça veut dire que c'est reparti pour vous
tout à retour au départ s'est jamais
arrêté j'ai tu sais j'ai fait at elle
dit certaine après cette histoire de
deux lames de la mauvaise vanne ou de la
vanne qui a eu lieu il ya trois ans ils
avaient dit les salles se sont invalidés
pas mauvais non
non non pas du tout alors
je me
répète fumer je n'adore je trouve
magnifique échange et patuc s'émousser
justement donc voilà donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai c'était une mauvaise blague
venant majoritairement la rue j'ai bien
du match et rim apple j'ai changé ma non
mais c'est pas ça le problème des
problèmes c'est toutes les blagues elles
ont un effet on va dire plus ou moins
pédagogique nous on fait on fait pas des
blagues par hasard quand on est jeune
mais oui ça ça veut dire les femmes
réagissent et laissez pas dire une chose
pareille ah ouais donc tu réagis là tu
vois tes berger pas été la seule en fait
la raison ttc et font rien pour vous tex
est ce que je sais pas si tu sais mais
regarde pour le défendre un an avant
pierre bénichou avait fait la même
oui à la radio regarder la radio
au beurre noir on ne dit plus rien on
l'a déjà expliqué dr
[Rires]
et tout le monde se marre et là tout le
monde s'est marré sait de quoi c'est qui
sont d'époque ça s'est joué à un an près
c'est quoi oui oui vraisemblablement pis
si tu veux plus y apparaissent n'y a pas
à s'expliquer ou à sa soirée expliqué
mel evans encore une fois elles sont
pédagogiques c'est difficile délicat
d'expliquer ça parce que je sens viendra
expliquer ce que c'est le métier
d'humoriste nous quand y'a un truc qui
kienké show faut qu'on y aille c'est
notre métier
sur le reflet d'une époque mais vous y
laissez passer
on ne peut pas laisser passer on est en
serre on s'est rassuré grâce ou quoi
voilà exactement en sorte que les choses
des potions nous de rire des choses
graves avant d'avoir à en pleurer très
bien ça c'est bien ça ça me redonne
c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous êtes sur scène et c'est
super on refaire de la télé est ce qu'il
ya ce qui est des gens qui reprennent
contact avec vous est ce que vous vous
prenez contact avec des patrons de
chaînes vous attention dit il ya des
projets toujours un petit peu dans l'air
mais parler de projets tant qu'ils sont
pas signés sert à rien elle vous pourrez
dire trois ans il ya une autre chose
aussi
c'est que
c'est marrant parce que c'est la chucky
m'a dit ça à chantal elle est sur scène
à la passe et 70 ans son talent et elle
me dit tu sais abandonné faut laisser la
place aux jeunes
c'est vraiment qu'elle me dit ça parce
que d'une certaine manière je veux bien
la croire pour savoir ouais ouais mais
moi j'ai que socom c'est alors je vous
dis toute la vérité on s'est rencontré
il ya un an un an et demi à peu près oui
et moi je voulais faire un documentaire
sur vous parce qu'avant on s'est
engueulés comme ça on va se dire la
vérité ici on s'est engueulé il est
demande initiée tellement vivant moi
j'étais à fond
et je te l'avais dit oui je remercie
la l'ont entendu bon et autres
rencontres d'hommes vous venez à t'en
vas dans les bureaux on se rend compte
que ça je dis moi j'adorerais ba
aujourd'hui fine mais c'est quoi la vie
de texte ou est ce que vous vivez tout
ça et même parce que je reste persuadé
que quand on est sincère on est toujours
sympathique et vous me dites oui et j'en
un premier temps j'avais dit oui voilà
chez moi je vous dirai pas plus quelle
chaîne parce que je prends mon temps à
polémique jeudi à la chaîne et la chaîne
me dis ok super c'est une super idée
d'heure et puis une semaine après la
chaîne ma peine vient je suis désolé
mais nous on a trop trop peur de la
fameuse cible femmes de la cible
ménagères on a trop peur qu'aujourd'hui
il fasse peur aux femmes est ce que est
ce qu'il ya eu ce vous avez eu ce
sentiment aussi est-ce que sur scène
vous l'avez us qu il comprenait quand
même et bien sûr que cette v2
pédagogique vous mais là oui bien sûr et
c'est pour ça qu'on dit que la télé
c'était mieux avant ces terres que
maintenant on a peur c'est à dire que le
sentiment moi je veut dégager c'est la
joie le bonheur le plaisir tu vois et
surtout la liberté est le contraire de
la liberté sont moins c'est la sécurité
donc en ce moment on se bat tous les
politiques se battent sur la sécurité la
sécurité doit on s'en fout moi je m'en
fous de la sécurité je veux bien prendre
des risques y aller mais tout le monde
veut être en sécurité fias des
précautions de langage des mots clés
qu'il faut pas dire externe faut pas se
mettre en sécurité nous les humoristes
ont dépensé que l'on doit y aller est-ce
que juste petite question vous ne pensez
pas qu'en fait tout ça finalement
c'était un simple prétexte peut-être et
que en fait finalement vous étiez un peu
l'animateur da et qu'aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'eux d'animateurs qui sont
peut-être un peu moins j'ai utilisé le
mot même un petit peu moins lourdingue
peut-être que c'est un peu ça aussi qui
a joué lourd taxe va peut-être faire
sauter un aplomb on va dire pour le
hamas que vous a jamais rappelés à
d'autres émissions dans nos gènes oui
mais mais je peux pas entendre ce mot là
puisque moi c'était mon fonds de
commerce et c'est un truc qui marche i a
changé bien non mais ça marchait sur le
marché plus vraiment qu'on a fait
ce qu'on a pu ni si les téléspectateurs
on a puni tout s'est tu finis les
téléspectateurs c'est qu'ils savent très
bien saignante un gros se débarrassant
de patrick drahi long on a vraiment pu
niveler les personnes les légendes plus
tôt elle est outrée aurait pu vous
rappeler depuis non mais écoutez écoute
ce que je suis en train de dire si tu
veux en faire dire un truc mais moi je
veux juste écoute bien on a puni les
téléspectateurs et on a on l'a on l'a on
a viré des émissions qu'ils aimaient ça
c'est bon les jeunes etc j'ai pas de
souci avec ça moi si on m'avait dit tu
es trop vieux dégage je jouerai bien
sondage ans c'est une question de style
non
non non non ça va passer mais si
j'écoutais xvi d'orge que les ex depuis
évidemment très longtemps on a fait le
métier longtemps on s'est côtoyé
beaucoup moi je suis assez d'accord avec
hugo ça c'est pertinent ce qu'il dit
pour une fois
est toujours d'accord
michel drucker pardon laurent ruquier
quelques-uns qui ont dépassé l'âge et il
peut pour arrêter la télé qui continue
avec succès donc ce n'est pas qu'une
question d'heures il ya un style est à
raison c'est vrai que soit l'heure
bigard toi vous veniez d'ailleurs
l'école clm est donc au guide l'école
voilà un peu plus à l'ancienne etc qui
nous a fait rire quand on était plus
jeunes moi honnêtement ça me ferait
moins rire aujourd'hui je te le dis de
manière la plus claire possible
j'entends jean tu en voilà parce que
parce que l'humour a changé le rythme de
l'humour a changé je pense que c'est
surtout ça a payé c'est pas simplement
l'âge et encore zidan alors à vannes un
peu ouais mais très intéressant que que
je d'abord on va passer quelques
extraits de ben c'est pas faux on était
et c'est bien domage
est-ce que vos éditions est ce que vos
émissions étaient et ait été montée
c'était des 26 minutes un désamour est
ce que c'est tout début elles n'étaient
pas montés d'accord tu débutes
j'arrivais j'avais une j2 ou ce passif
est à presque 20 ans et on me disait tu
voudrais pas un peu faire des joggings
avant de venir faire des missions que tu
sois un peu plus fatigué j'avais une
énergie de ouf et après ils ont commencé
à être montées et étaient coupées et
coupez coupez on
était un peu trop par moments c'est de
commencer mes hommages parce que nous
vraiment sur le plateau on se marre
énormément et voilà c'est un peu dommage
on va passer des extraits de la télé
c'était mieux avant vous allez voir
quand même mais j'ai lu l'interview vous
avez dit pardon on peut il est plus
président maintenant on s'en fiche mais
vous avez 10 à partir de sarkozy que la
télé a été compliqué c'est vrai ça c'est
à partir du moment où il ya eu une
omniprésence et un retour de
l'omniprésent sur les programmes télé ça
nous regarde alors apparaître la télé
c'était mieux avant ou pas moi je suis
un peu parti aussi des générations où je
trouvais que c'était dix fois mieux
avant et qu'on est paniquée de tous
aujourd'hui mardi dans la salle r nos
blagues de tout on est comme ça en
permanence me dirais que c'est une
horreur regardez par exemple ce qui
s'est passé c'était chez g tech et 2
chavannes à l'époque vous avez fait un
débat lancé le mardi regardez comme
c'était parti à la mémoire des 14
millions d'allemands qui ont été
déportés en 1945 et 1946 deux millions
de morts
[Musique]
c'était à 22h30 sur terre un kama
je me souviens pourquoi est-ce que je
bossais déjà dans l'équipe de chabannes
à l'époque c'est arte geie on est on est
on commençait à me reprocher c'est
olivier delacroix l'animateur de france
2 que vous connaissez tous avec d azur
qui avait monté ce plateau et qui était
un de ceux qui montaient les plateaux un
peu un peu raide donc on savait qu'on
avait un nazillon il savait qu'on avait
un nazillon sur leur je pense qu'il a dû
faire venir des copains du betar qui est
un mouvement juif un peu un peu cossue
au niveau muscles et voilà ils sont
tombés dessus c'était un truc était un
peu prévu jamais réellement vous montre
un exemple extrême maintenance et si on
le passe est aujourd'hui mais marei je
pense qu'il sera sorti dans la seconde
c'est la gaffe qui faisait dans son
émission sur tf1 l' accent africain
ensuite ça aujourd'hui on est mort c'est
dommage d'ailleurs les accents c'est
super drôle film à
regarder l'extrait moi je regarde
ce qu'ils ont trouvé lever la main alors
qu'il avait demandé fois qu'il a gagné
[Musique]
c'est vrai vous
ai bien découvert le rouge mais ça
paraît fou aujourd'hui en plus c'était
un peu s'il fait un peu comme ça
est ce que c'est moi ces textes qui
m'intéresse parce que vous êtes
humoriste aussi lui aussi bien il fait
partie de l'école club med et tout ça
vous regrettez ça parce que c'est est-ce
que c'est du racisme pour vous ça ne
mange pas du racisme c'est aller à
l'époque moi je les fais beaucoup si
j'adorais quand il y avait des
candidatures qui est jouée africaine qui
parlait il y avait l on se parlait comme
ça tous les oeufs et elle y avait c'est
comme ça qu'on allait à des révélations
lui aussi touché autre chose là tout
d'un coup c'est une animation n'est pas
avec les candidats - c'est avec les
candidats ont parlé on avait des vraies
révélations il faut entrer dans les
univers des gens de personnes s'adonnent
quelle révélation page merci merci me
lâcher
ça me choque mais la révolte a droit
bien
des accents que la loi de fait on fait
l'action mais aussi plus blâmer personne
ne trouvait rien
les belges eux n'ont pas signalé un
moment fort et vers hugo cie on va
l'assumer ça me fait hurler de rire
quand on quand on quand on me man
homosexualité mentor c'est un trio les
drire et je suis gay je regardais tous
les visages hilares et mais ces
personnes ne sont rien ne rigolait
aujourd'hui mais est ce que c'est un
bien aujourd'hui la salle où ça ne
marche plus et non pas faire parce que
surtout on n'est pas client vous surtout
vous cette génération là je parle encore
encore plus de wii de moins en moins de
gens sont payants des affranchis pardon
et la gaffe il a quitté les antennes de
tf1 avec des millions de personnes qui a
battu je crois juste dire une chose
vraiment importante
alors juste de la santé texas est même
pas le problème qu'elle soit drôle ou
pas c'est qu'elle en grand les entraîne
un racisme ordinaire
ridiculise un langage on stigmatise une
population animeront les hôpitaux et on
n'en retire que commerciaux ils
appellent bertrand des 4 500 bertrand
deckers
les belles
communauté
éducative
c'est un débat là-dessus moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était d'abord c'est de
savoir qui va très bien les amis
aujourd'hui je vous laisse vous secret à
ce que vous voulez vous embrouiller
adorent ils regardent de loin c'est
rigolo de vous entendre vous embrouiller
ce qu'est moi je vous ai dit que le mot
le plus important au monde
c'est la liberté oui ce que vous êtes en
train de faire vous êtes en train
d'entraver vos propres libertés
continuer si vous voulez mais moi je
veux être libre de tout faire voilà la
liberté c'est ça il ya un monsieur
derrière qui dit bravo c'est ça qui est
ça c'est ça ben voilà maintenant et
c'est ce qu'ont emprunté des inconnus
sous serre elle s'est quand même connu
ça aussi un jeu un peu près de la même
génération que moi ouais ouais ouais
donc je comprends qu'il fasse
moi j'étais gosse qu'on 26 24 et 18 ans
quand on discute de ça avec eux en
disant mais nous ça nous faisait rire
ils disent ouais mais à force de rire
des homos à force de rire des belges à
force des blondes à partir des procès
est-ce que fabre a l'impression que le
racisme ordinaire dont tu parlais tout à
l'heure il existe et qu'il faudrait
peut-être arrêter un peu de se moquer de
certaines
personnes
frelot illimité personnel un truc ferait
plus rire aujourd'hui c'est une question
d'époque c'est très très dur et c'est
pour ça que je défends aussi télé moi je
suis très heureux qu'ils soient
jean-michel je t'adore mais fernand
raynaud il a mis limitait tous les
accents non mais je dirais même si les
a's et je vous ai pas l'accent ça fait
plus rire
bien sûr que c'est ce qui est compliqué
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on juge aujourd'hui
les gens avec des entre guillemets à
fort en juge les anciens avec les lois
d'aujourd'hui quand j'ai vu qu
effectivement y'a pas longtemps on est
tombé sur michel leeb à qui on a dit
qu'il faisait ce qu'elle faisait en
africain il ya 20 ans on rie et tous
deux ont valu faire qu'on peut pas lui
faire le procès aujourd'hui on est le
nom le pistard tu as raison le plus
important c'est d'être droit dans ses
bottes et d'être content du chemin qu'on
a fait moi je suis assez fier du chemin
que j'ai fait et je trouve que c'est
même pas une erreur c'est cette blague
tu vois enfin ça a été ça a été jugée
comme une mais y'a aucune blanc
l'ambiance globale sauverait sur le
service public dans un jeu qui parle de
couple tu aurais bien il
était sur le plateau
s'est effectivement cette blague ou
l'arrêté pas en revanche
je regrette ça c'est en pleurs que ça
prend autour d'une blague c'est ça que
j'aurais je regrette la légèreté de
l'époque sur sa conduite était mieux
avant oui on la légèreté et le fait
qu'on était dans un pays libre et on est
en train de perdre 5 moussavi
lire et je la fais les plus faire quoi
vous le saviez ce que juste avant de
dire la blague dix morts je vais dire
est une blague devra t elle à faire la
fée dont moussa dia consciemment
québécois et changer quand même nous
savions que ça veut dire que j'aurais pu
j'aurais dit oui j'aurais d'ailleurs
slavik fallait pas l'intérêt du pas
venir à cette émission non et fidjiens
c'est ça que c'est ça que ça entraîne
derrière dingue rentrons pas dans cette
polémique parce qu'on est là plutôt bien
sûr du froid mais on est un peu moins
fun mais s'il faut que ça reste fun cela
dit ça reste fun bon film adaptation
des amis voilà vous dire aujourd'hui moi
il ya un type qui dit pohdh qui fait
rire tout le monde tous les soirs on va
faire un peu de cyril hanouna excuse moi
tu peux faire rire sans faire forcément
des
avis des choses extrêmement hard parfois
syrie il va très loin dans l'humour
allez sur youtube regardez quelques
humoristes sur youtube ils vont très
loin tant à dire mais sa mère son vieux
moi ça fait plaisir c'est de savoir que
vous êtes sur scène voilà ça on l'a vu
voilà